close back to class for many charter and
private schools today
some are starting the new year online
others are meeting in person
and that includes one lutheran private
school up in the northwest our hector
mejia shows us how they welcome students
back into the classroom masks
temperature checks and hand sanitizing
stations
that's how mountain view lutheran school
rolls out a new academic year
during the coronavirus pandemic it's
eight in the morning in mr wiltsy's
fifth grade class
with a pencil bag that says girls can do
anything
ali santos braces for a year like no
other obviously for safety reasons but
sort of not fun to
not be able to play around with your
friends like you used to the private
lutheran school which is in the
northwest has about a hundred students
face to face instruction is actually the
only option they offer
classroom sizes are capped at no more
than 50 percent capacity to comply with
governor's orders and once inside
students will notice that their desks
are three feet apart
we've learned class itself will sound
very different
according to principal chris schneider
we usually teach spanish in grades three
four and five
this year we're actually switching over
to asl to american sign language
and that's uh that's because we don't
want kids speaking too much
to have aerosols going around the room
he says parents searching for in-person
instruction
have turned to charter or private
schools kyle and candace larson for
example
said they pulled their son cody out of
the clark county school district
i feel that interaction with people is
so important
in your development they were hoping to
snap a picture and freeze this moment in
time
but covet 19 restrictions kept parents
like the larsons
from going inside reporting from the
northwest hector mejia
8 news now